et pris connaissance des résultats
c'était quand même une surprise et une
grande responsabilité qui nous attend on
comprend que vous êtes surpris creissan
marot vous vous attendiez pas à
finalement l'emporter on va dire aussi
largement sur un maire sortant dont on
sait qu'il a forcément des réseaux la
capacité de mobiliser tout à fait on
pensait que c'était une élection qui
allait se jouer à un ou deux points est
donc là apparemment il ya dix points
d'écart pratiquement donc c'est quand
même un manifeste donc et je tiens à
remercier les prés de 50% des auxerrois
qui ont voulu exprimer leur volonté de
changement
donc c'est à dire c'est une belle
victoire
vous avez souhaité très peu politisés
sur cette campagne on en a parlé
ensemble dans les débats qu'on a
organisées
c'est quoi vous êtes plus jean pierre
soisson ça c'est forcément un nom auquel
on pense quand on est élu maire
d'auxerre où vous êtes aussi guillaume
larrivé le député de l'yonne qui dont
vous êtes très proche par ailleurs alors
ni l'un ni l'autre puisque jean pierre
soisson c'est une figure emblématique de
l'ancien roi je n'ai pas cette
prétention là guillaume larrivé c'est un
parlementaire qu'il y travaille très
bien d'ailleurs donc j'ai pas non plus
la prétention d'être parlementaire
c'est simplement une marque de fabrique
d'une équipe qui a beaucoup travaillé
qui est très solidaire très dynamique
très compétente et donc c'est ceux des
valeurs qu'on a développé tous ensemble
durant c'est presque sept mois de
campagne et suite à cette crise
sanitaire qui a été une vraie épreuve
dans cette équipe et qui a relevé ce
challenge
la première